the worsening humanitarian crisis in
ukraine an attempt to evacuate civilians
from five ukrainian cities today seems
to have largely failed moscow agreed to
establish humanitarian corridors but
ukraine claims russian troops resumed
shelling on the route leading away from
the city of maryupo
while some residents of the northern
city of sumi have reportedly managed to
flee ukraine's government shared this
video that you see right here which
shows red cross buses evacuating people
before nightfall when the ceasefire ends
wasumi has seen heavy civilian
casualties local authorities say an
airstrike last night killed at least 21
people while despite the increasing
death toll the ukrainian military says
that russia is seeing major setbacks and
its advance has slowed significantly
it's almost two weeks since russia
invaded ukraine
but the capital still stands
the anthem
now a morning ritual
while russian shelling continues to
leave its scars on ukraine
like here
in the key battleground of harkiev
the people fight on
go home they chant
standing just meters away from their
armed adversaries
speaking from kiev where he is vowed to
remain ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky said that peace was possible
so we will talk
we will insist on negotiations until we
find a way to tell our people
this is how we will come to peace
at kiev's central station
the exodus to western ukraine and beyond
continues
levi's mayor said the city is buckling
under the pressure
struggling to feed the hundreds of
thousands seeking refuge
and dealing with the hundreds of
thousands more
who pass through this city before
traveling on to other countries
as of today
level has become the refuge for 200 000
people
who moved to la viv hiding from
bombardments and rocket strikes
i want to appeal to all international
organizations for help
we need your support
we need your direct participation here
in levies
ukrainian officials speak of a slowing
russian advance
but as the shelling continues
and civilian casualties rise
the horrors of this war
remain devastatingly clear
alexander van naman is at the front
lines of the refugee crisis she's in
levite which has become a hub for
ukrainians fleeing russian attacks
alexandra are refugees still pouring in
tel aviv where you are and what are they
sharing with you about their experiences
people that are arriving here have been
through a lot they are telling us about
the ways how they escaped russian
artillery assaults how they had to hide
in their basements and many of them are
deeply traumatized let's take tatiana
for example i met her here she is from
harkeef and we started talking in
russian because she is from the
russian-speaking part of the country and
she told me about her beautiful hometown
that i also know and then she burst it
into tears because she reminded herself
that parts of the city now are turned
into rubble and she was worrying
sick about her mom who decided to stay
there and she doesn't know whether her
mom is okay or not and as you can see
there are a lot of such stories that we
are hearing and people want to share
them because they want the world to know
what's happening here
do uh i mean you're in la vie which has
turned into a hub for people trying to
make it to safety as best they can can
the city still handle the influx of
refugees
well the more people arrive here the
more difficult it's going to be
according to the mayor the city is being
stretched to its limits already and he
also said today that
it could be that the near future they
will not be able to provide the refugees
with a safe place to stay of course what
people need is food warm clothes
medicines but first and foremost they
need a place to stay they are staying in
hotels they are staying in apartments
but we met a number of people today who
told us that they don't have a place to
stay and that is one of the reasons why
we are here at the railway station that
you can hear see behind me that are
still a lot of people trying to get to
the polish border trying to get to
poland to other european countries to
feel safe there
alexander phenomenon reporting from la
viv in ukraine alexander thank you so
much for your continued coverage
and i'd like to take you now to the
ukrainian capital of kiev to kiera rudig
she's a member of the ukrainian
parliament and leader of the liberal
pro-european hollows party kyra a very
uh warm welcome to dw news on day 13 of
this war i just want to ask you how are
you kobe
hello thank you for having me
well it's 13th day and our cities are
still standing though
the whole world was saying that we will
fail after 24 to 48 hours so i'm like
watch us
i am super devastated and hurted by all
the pain and suffering that i see when
the refugees are fleeing through kiev
when we are taking refugees from the
outskirts of kiev that were bombarded by
the russian
missiles and bombs
i am super frustrated when we see
children in bomb shelters but i'm also
motivated because i see my resistance
team training because i see so many
people in kiev in the whole country
helping each other and we are getting
ready to give russian forces that are
coming to the capital and will come here
pretty soon we are happy to give them a
good fight
because what they are trying to take
from us they will not be able to we are
preparing for a siege we are preparing
for a fight we are preparing for every
uh kind of event however there is one
thing that we cannot help ourselves with
we cannot use our rifles for is the air
force attacks and this is why we
continuously asking for a no-fly zone or
anything in particular similar like the
no-fly zone so we can protect ourselves
and so that my country has a chance to
win this war
now unfortunately of course nato
says they will not be able to provide
that that no-fly zone is a no-go for
nato i want to refer to
when the invasion was launched by russia
you posted a photo that went viral i
want to
pull that up and show it to our viewers
it's you in your apartment holding a
kalashnikov you explained how you never
held a weapon in your hands before but
you were getting ready to defend
your country and obviously just hearing
you speak right now
your resolve to defend your country are
you are you ready to fight i know it's
almost a redundant question because you
already outlined your resolve
uh yes i'm ready to fight i have been
training along with my resistance team
that we put together
the day one of the war i have been
training with them
two hours every day so now i'm much
better
with the rifle than i was when this
picture was taken
i'm training and i'm we're being a part
of the larger resistance teams and we
are getting ready to
uh oppose russian troops to fight
russian troops uh if they come to the
city
we know that the capital has been
a major goal for russians and for putin
personally and this is why it will be a
tough uh goal to protect it and this is
why we are staying here men as well as
women
to
be able to have all the hands that we
have
that could hear who could bear arms to
bear the arms and to be able to
protect what is ours right now
what is the situation in kiev right now
i mean obviously we have seen some very
worrying developments russia unleashing
mass bombardments
in terms of of the situation in and
around kiev what can you tell us about
that
so inside kiev
we are doing i would say normal except
for the heavy bombarding that is
happening so it's uh up to 10 times when
the sirens go on and you have to go to
the bomb shelter 10 times a day and
imagine it's being like family with the
children so it's terrifying and
devastating and
and at some point you feel frightened
because you get used to it this is the
worst thing you get used to to bombard
your city being bombarded and we are
very worried about the outskirts of the
city that
where people have to leave their homes
because because they just
don't have homes anymore because they
were destroyed and we are worried about
the
russian troops surrounding the city we
know that they are trying to take on the
entrances and exits to the city and
obviously our goal is not to let them do
that
so this is how the fight happens we want
to make sure that we are not under siege
and they are trying to
circle the city and do the humanitarian
catastrophe as they have done in
mariupol where children are dying
of dehydration in 21st century children
are dying of dehydration in the european
country can you believe this
can you believe that this is happening
to us right now so i will be begging i
will be asking i will be persuading
everybody who is in charge right now to
give us the jets to give us the rockets
to give us the missiles anything so we
can protect ourselves so in 21st century
children wouldn't have to die of
dehydration
before i let you go i mean everyone as
you've outlined there in very stark
terms is suffering incredibly
um
this is almost
ridiculous to ask you but international
women's day is today what does it mean
to be a woman in ukraine today
it is
it's when instead of flowers that you're
supposed to be carrying today you're
carrying guns
but i'm privileged to be carrying guns
today and stand shoulder to shoulder
with the men of ukraine
you know when putin was
attempting to
conquer us he only calculated men in his
math he didn't calculate that ukrainian
women and the whole ukrainian nation
will be standing up to him
everybody their own way but everybody
strong as one and this is why we are
fighting him so hard and this is why in
13 days of war with the largest army in
the world we are still standing and we
will be standing and we will win
kira rudik member of the euro ukrainian
parliament thank you very much
we wish you
safety thank you and glory to ukraine